que mouctar diallo président du parti
nouvelles forces démocratiques ministre
de la jeunesse et de l'emploi des jeunes
de la république de guinée bonsoir merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous sur rt france
demain donc élections présidentielles
avec un rat face à face avec le
président sortant est ce que ça va se
transformer en un référendum contre un
troisième mandat écoutez je pense que
vous avez l'occasion de suivre le
déroulement de la campagne
tu vas au moins je pense que les
observateurs ont bien vu la popularité
la forte adhésion des populations à la
cause ou à la candidature du candidat du
président du personnes afin qu'on dise
si les enceintes internationales dans
les quatre régions naturelles la zone
spéciale de conakry où toutes ces zones
ont rivalisé d'ardeur d'un pisias sme
beaucoup justement pour recevoir pour
acclamer pour exprimer leur haine de
ceux qui de soutien au président alpha
condé
donc nous sommes absolument certains que
demain dimanche 18 octobre 2010 2020 moi
ce sera une date cette consécration ou
de renouvellement du mois m dans le
public le peuple de guinée il que moi
dans sa majorité écrasante fota pour le
président tout le calme est de brienne
le premier mandat de la 4ème république
comment est-ce que vous expliquer ces
tensions qui ont eu lieu pendant pendant
la campagne et coûteux toit pour tous
tripy l'ambiance électorale particulière
ne peut pas être comme une situation
simple de l'élection savez les élections
sont des occasions de compétition entre
plusieurs candidats et donc ce sont deux
périodes caractérisées par liszt mans
par l'expression de passions nier aux
soutiens de candidats en lice est donc
c'est normal ce qu'il y ait la tension
c'est normal justement que chacun
exprime son soutien à son candidat de
soutien portant ses références or
justement que cette passion que cet
enthousiasme cette mobilisation ne
déborde pas et les occasions d urgence
ce que nous avons toujours dit et ce
qu'il faut saluer aussi leurs différents
candidats
ils sont empêchés l'apaisement pour que
les élections se passent dans de bonnes
conditions
il est vrai que ya eu deux à des
endroits
c'est notamment à la vie à tabac ou le
problème du communisme n'est pas très
bien été cassé par les militants de
l'ufdg
il ya eu aussi du côté de caen où c'est
uma le candidat du fg ne se sont elles
un diallo a été bloqué par les jeunes
moi-même siège d'un parti nfd nouvelles
forces démocratiques membres de la
connaît donc soutien du coup il faudra
compter en amont sièges
à pâques et l'été dernier par des
militants de lire ce que j'ai tout
simplement parce que on y avait obligé
fortement nos meetings pour soutenir
leur faconde et non en dehors de deux de
ses heures justement donc qu'on en a
conclu que nous consacrons coup d'en
constater je pense que globalement on
peut dire que les choses sont en train
de se mettre en place pour que les
élections puissent avoir lieu et qui
ment de façon à pisé et la commission de
transparence à une partie des guinéens
réprouvant touquet ce troisième mandat
cette troisième candidature en tout cas
d'alpha condé à l'instar de ce qui se
passe en côte d'ivoire vous comprenez
que l'alternance soit souhaité par une
partie de la population
écoutez nous sommes en démocratie c'est
normal que des positions soient
étudiants et qu'elle s'exprime mais ils
doivent s'exprimer dans le cas des lois
de la république
il est normal que certains justement
politiques qui veulent aller au pouvoir
aussi s'oppose à une autre candidature
que nous n'avons pas trois mandats mais
que nous appelons les malades la 4ème
république aux exactions normal que des
partis politiques qui sont de
l'opposition actuellement qui veulent
exercer le pouvoir
ces moments qui se posent à la can où la
turquie n'a pas compté dans la
popularité est contestable
quand vous l'avez constaté pourquoi
l'audit premier mandat de la quatrième
république pardonnez moi pourquoi vous
dites premier mandat de la quatrième
république
oui en fait pas qu'il ya eu une nouvelle
constitution qui a été adoptée votre
écran dont est donc de six mois nous
sommes dans une catégorie et donc et
tout cas de nature oublier merlus
stratégie plane sur la balle
de cette nouvelle constitution s'inscrit
dans le cadre justement un peu mes
mandats et pour cette nouvelle
république
mais ce qui est important c'est de
permettre au peuple de s'exprimer qu'à
la souveraineté anciens au peuple et
donc je ne vois pas pourquoi on peut
empêcher l'expression oui oui je vous
écoute on pourrait évidemment le peuple
doit s'exprimer dans de bonnes
conditions vous garantissez le bon
déroulement en tout cas de ces élections
demain oui mais je suis même principal
le principal opposant qui est candidat
aux élections ou s'ils veulent y allons
donc les yeux qui a dit que sa direction
actuelle m'a dit au regard des
conditions d'organisation de l'élection
la moins dure de foot que par rapport
aux élections passées donc c'est ce
qu'un acteur majeur qui fait témoignages
qu'on regarde de l'information qui ne
tient pas ce qu'il va des représentants
au niveau de la commission le conseil
électoral ne soit indépendante ceni qui
est l'organe qui est l'organe qui
organise les élections où l'opposition
et le présenter de façon paritaire avec
la mouvance présidentielle est donc cet
organe qui ne d'élections avec l'appui
de la communauté internationale et la
communauté africains notamment la cedeao
l'intérêt de fonds qui a été fait
assaini le fichier électoral et pour
mettre en place ce tome à tous les
garde-fous pour permettre l'organisation
d'élections paisibles
c'est dans ce contexte justement comme
ceux de renault a dit qu'il ya moins de
risque de
[Musique]
merci merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
oktar diallo d'avoir répondu en direct à
nos questions sur rt france merci